good day to you
and welcome to this webinar that is part
of the idf webinars on managing calves
from birth to weaning in different parts
of the world
my name is giulio django
i am a senior scientist at the
international livestock research
institute based in nairobi kenya
in the work i do
we seek to identify appropriate breeds
and breed combinations for livestock
production systems in middle and low
income countries
in order to improve animal productivity
and improve incomes for the millions of
people who depend on livestock
for their livelihoods
in this webinar
prepared in combination with other
members of the livestock genetics team
at ilray
i will share information on smallholder
farming systems in eastern africa
the title of our presentation is
raising carbs
a strategic investment for small holder
farmers in east africa
why is this strategic
the continent of africa is estimated to
have 1.3 billion people
about one-fifth of this population lives
on less than two dollars per day
yet africa hosts more than 20 percent of
the world's cattle
in spite of the huge cattle population
africa produces less than six percent of
the global milk from cattle
eighty percent of the milk produced in
africa is by small holder farmers
it is interesting to note that 43
of the agricultural workforce in africa
is female
there is a huge gap in productivity by
dairy animals depending on the farming
system in which they are raised as is
illustrated in the chart for the east
africa region
you note dairy cattle
raised by the majority of smallholder
farmers produce less than 2 000
kilograms of milk in an annual lactation
yet within the same environment
large-scale producers are able to
produce
up to 6500 kilograms per lactation from
the same type of animals
what is the nature of dairy production
in the small holder farms
typically
small holder farms
are 0.5 to 5 acres in size
the farmers engage in both crop and
livestock enterprises
they generally own 2 to 5 dairy cattle
one or two of the animals will usually
be in milk
while the rest of the herd is comprised
of animals of mixed age and sex
categories
the cattle are raised under different
management conditions depending on their
age and physiological status
mature milking animals
are often kept in barns
or stalls
while younger animals are left to graze
in the fields
on residues from crops
or by the roadsides
animals put to graze by the roadside
are tethered to a fixed pole or tree
using a length of rope to ensure that
they do not stray
the animals in stalls
have limited space for movement
and are provided with feed and water by
the farmer
these systems
are referred to as the cut and carry
or
zero grazing production systems
the animals reared for dairy production
have a high proportion of exotic
genotype
that is the host and frisian
archive
jersey or brown swiss blood types
however
the milk productivity tends to be much
lower than that of the same breeds in
some of the more developed countries
though the milk production per animal
is less than 12 liters per day from two
milkings in the smallholder systems
the dairy cows are a critical source of
daily income for the farmers
the newborn calf
is generally left with its mother for
the first week of its life
that is three to seven days
in a field or enclosure that is well
sheltered from strong winds
during this time
the calf is allowed to suckle at any
time
at the same time the cow is hand milked
twice a day
in the morning and in the evening in
order to enhance milk let down
cows in small holder systems are milked
by hand
as most farmers do not have milking
machines
the milk extracted by the milka
is given to the calf using a bucket from
the third day of its life
as the calf is taught to feed from a
bucket in addition to suckling from its
mother
in this way
the colostrum from the cow is all
provided for the calf
after the first week
milk produced
is used both by the calf and the farm
household
excess milk is sold to generate an
income
at the end of the first week
the calf is also separated from its
mother
and is housed in a shed that protects it
from extreme cold or heat
while the mother is left to graze or
feed in a nearby stall or paddock
in the first month following carving
farmers pay critical attention to their
calves
they ensure the carbs are provided with
sufficient milk
and take time to bond with the calf so
that it is used to human contact
as cows are hand milked
in some instances
the calf is permitted to suckle from its
mother in order to help stimulate milk
let down at the times of milking
once milk is flowing freely the calf is
removed and the handler continues to
milk the cow
at the end of the milking session
the calf is again permitted to circle
the mother and extract any remaining
milk
this practice
is used to prevent incidences of
mastitis due to incomplete milking by
the handler
a measured portion of the extracted milk
is provided to the growing calf using a
bucket
after the first month of its life
the calf is moved to a further distance
from the cow and circling is discouraged
milk for the calf is fully provided
using a bucket
the farmers thus control the amount of
milk that is provided for their carbs
depending on the age of the calf
the common practice is for milk to be
provided
such that
in the first month
the calf is given up to six liters of
milk each day
divided into three feeding times
in the morning
at midday
and in the evening
in the second month
milk for the calf is gradually reduced
to four liters per day
divided into two feeding times in the
morning and in the evening
at this stage
the calves are also exposed to good
quality fresh forage
to begin to stimulate the rumen
and are provided with some quantity
of clean water and mineral lick
farmers with more resources
also provide calf starter pellets for
their calves
in the third month
the milk provided for the calf is
gradually reduced to two liters per day
and in the fourth month
the carbs are fully weaned off milk
and are provided with green forage
in addition to being left to graze on
crop residues
in the first two months of their lives
calves are normally housed in raised
pens
this is to ensure that they are
protected from external parasites that
are often found in open fields
the calf pen is washed with their
carricides twice a week to prevent
infestation with ticks
and to protect the calves against
different diseases
the carbs are also washed with a gentle
pyrethrin-based aquaricide
male calves are usually castrated soon
after birth if they are not earmarked
for breeding
there are often several challenges that
are experienced when raising carbs
within the small holder systems
one of the main challenges is under
feeding of the calves
due to competition for milk
between the farmer household and the
calf
in some instances
the herders dilute the milk provided to
the calves with too much water
this results in water poisoning
diarrhea
in calves is also a common challenge
as the feeding containers may not have
been well cleaned
farmers are encouraged to use
disinfectants and the strong sunlight to
help ensure that the containers are
clean and dry prior to putting the milk
in for the calves
when environmental conditions are cold
the calves sometimes contact pneumonia
because of the drafts and the sudden
changes in weather
it is important that the farmers provide
adequate housing for the calves in this
early stage of their lives
to encourage improved dairy production
livestock extension service providers
normally visit the smallholder farmers
there are also several training courses
for small holder farmers on proper
management of carbs provided by both
national
and development partners
with the cobit pandemic in 2020
it has been a challenge to access the
smallholder farmers
the ilre livestock genetics team
developed and availed
mobile phone-based extension materials
using different web applications that
are freely available to the small holder
farmers
following a simple online registration
process
the training content is turned into fun
interactive lessons
and quizzes to help guide the farmers
and also to encourage younger household
members to take an interest in managing
the animals
the tools are available
in the main languages used in east
africa
currently
there are four courses available for the
users
you are welcome to ask any questions on
the information shared in this webinar
thank you for your attention